Usa el método de sustitución para encontrar
"x" y para encontrar "y".
Y aquí tenemos dos ecuaciones,
"y" es igual a "-5x" más 8
y acá abajo "10x" más "2y" igual a -2.
Y el método de sustitución en general es
que si tenemos una variable en función de la otra,
la podemos meter
adentro de la otra ecuación
y es justo lo que voy a utilizar
porque aquí me dice que "y"
tiene que ser igual a "-5x" más 8,
por lo tanto,
en lugar de esta "y" voy a meter "-5x" más 8 sustituyéndola de la primera ecuación,
porque yo sé que se tienen que cumplir
ambas ecuaciones simultáneamente,
por lo tanto vamos a ponerlo aquí,
en lugar de "y" voy a poner "-5x" más 8
y como la primera ecuación es cierta,
entonces vamos a sustituir el valor de "y",
utilizando la información
que me dice la primera ecuación.
Entonces vamos a meterla aquí
y vamos a ver que es lo que me queda.
Y si yo enchufo a "y" igual a "-5x" más 8
en la segunda ecuación,
me va a quedar "10x" más 2 por "y",
pero en lugar de "y" voy a enchufar "-5x" más 8
más 2 que va a multiplicar a "y",
pero "y" vale "-5x" más 8,
"-5x" más 8, esto tiene que ser igual a -2.
Y bueno, después voy a distribuir a este
2 por todo lo que está dentro del paréntesis,
entonces ya tengo una ecuación
con solamente una incógnita,
¿y qué me va a quedar?
2 por -5 y 2 por 8, 2 por "-5x" me va a quedar
"-10x", "10x" menos "10x" y 2 por 8 es 16,
entonces más 16, "-10x" más 16,
esto tiene que ser igual a -2.
Y bueno, aquí tengo "10x" menos "10x",
estos dos se pueden cancelar,
estos dos se pueden ir,
estos dos me dan 0,
por lo tanto los voy a tachar
y voy a hacer como si no existen
y me queda que 16 es igual a -2...
¿y 16 es igual a -2?
Esto no tiene sentido,
¿qué pasó aquí?
¿qué pasó con este sistema de ecuaciones?
Y cuando llegamos a resultados
de este estilo tan bizarros,
resulta que tenemos
un sistema inconsistente,
16 nunca es igual a -2.
Por lo tanto, esto es un resultado inconsistente
y este sistema de ecuaciones es inconsistente,
¿a qué me refiero?
a que no existe ninguna "x" y "y" que cumplan
estas dos ecuaciones simultáneamente,
dicho de otra manera,
estamos hablando de dos rectas paralelas...
Es más, déjame graficarlas para que te des
cuenta a qué me estoy refiriendo.
Fíjate bien, aquí tengo mi eje de las "x",
aquí tengo mi eje de las "y"
y la primera ecuación ya está en la forma
pendiente-ordenada al origen,
así que vamos a graficarla.
5, 6, 7 y 8...
Entonces por aquí corta mi eje de las "y"
y tiene una pendiente de -5,
por lo tanto va hacia abajo
con una pendiente de -5,
vamos a suponer que esta es la gráfica
de mi primera ecuación.
Ahora, mi segunda ecuación,
no está en forma pendiente-ordenada al origen,
por lo tanto vamos a despejar a "y".
Entonces tengo "10x" más "2y"
esto es igual a -2 y ahora,
voy a restar "10x"
de ambos lados de la ecuación,
de tal manera que me queda
que "2y" es igual a "-10x" menos 2.
Y ahora voy a dividir todo entre 2
y entonces me queda que "y" es igual a "-5x" menos 1,
dividiendo todo entre 2.
Y date cuenta que tenemos la misma pendiente,
es una recta paralela,
solamente que esta recta corta en -1,
son rectas paralelas,
fíjate bien,
tenemos la misma pendiente,
solamente que una distinta ordenada al origen
y entonces son dos rectas paralelas,
las rectas paralelas
nunca se intersectan,
por eso se dice que este sistema
es un sistema inconsistente.
Cuando llegamos a algo de la forma
16 es iguala -2
o una constante igual a otra
que no son la misma,
entonces hablamos de un sistema
inconsistente y por lo tanto,
podemos concluir que no existe una "x" y una "y",
que satisfagan ambas ecuaciones simultáneamente.
No tenemos solución alguna.